die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen den Sport hat
Norbert Lehmann für sie ganz schönen
guten Abend von mir die Koalition hat
sich auf ein heizungsgesetz verständigt
jetzt also doch das umstrittene
heizungsgesetz soll noch diese Woche in
den Bundestag allerdings in veränderter
Form
viel Geld für schweres Leid die
katholische Kirche muss ein
Missbrauchsopfer 300.000 Euro zahlen ein
Urteil mit Signalwirkung
und was darf Anwohnerparken Kosten das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht kippt zwar die
Regeln in Freiburg stürzt sich aber
nicht an deutlich höheren Gebühren
[Musik]
lange wurde in der Ampelkoalition über
das heizungsgesetz gestritten jetzt
steht eine grundsatzreinigung und die
sieht Änderungen zum vorherigen Entwurf
vor so soll das Gesetz etwa nur dort
gelten wo eine kommunale wärmeplanung
vorliegt das soll bis spätestens 2028
bundesweite Fall sein das Gesetz soll
noch diese Woche zur Beratung in den
Bundestag und könnte so bis zur
Sommerpause verabschiedet werden Andreas
Reichstag am Nachmittag in einem
Hinterzimmer der SPD-Fraktion treffen
sich Bundeskanzler Scholz Vizekanzler
Harbeck und FDP-Chef Lindner es gilt den
gordischen Knoten zu durchschlagen den
gordischen Knoten der da heiß Gebäude
Energiegesetz die Frage also wie
Deutschland künftig Heizen wird die
Fronten verhärtet seit Wochen wollen die
Unterhändler der ampelpartei nicht
zusammenfinden kein Kompromiss in sich
der grüne Wirtschaftsminister macht am
Morgen den Ernst der Lage klar da geht
es jetzt inzwischen dann auch um mehr
als nur um dieses gewerbegesetz sondern
die Regierung sollte jetzt schon ihre
Regierungsfähigkeit in der Beweis
stellen deshalb das Krisengespräch der
Regierung Spitzen und das fruchtet die
Ampel verständigt sich auf einen
Kompromiss es war gut dass Vertreter der
Regierung da gewesen sind der
Bundeskanzler der Finanzminister und der
Wirtschaftsminister weil wir natürlich
auch Fachfragen gehabt haben die
technologieoffenheit ist in die
Leitplanken die wir vereinbart haben
vollumfänglich gewährleistet
ab dem ersten 24 können auch nach wie
vor beispielsweise Gasheizung verbaut
werden was gut und richtig ist grundlage
ist die kommunale wärmeplanung darin
wird festgestellt wer wie heizen kann
liegt beispielsweise Fernwärme kann
diese genutzt werden eine neue
klimaneutrale Heizung muss dann nicht
eingebaut werden es gibt an dieser
Stelle keinen Abstrich beim Thema
Klimaschutz aber die Leute haben mehr
Zeit sich zu entscheiden und damit haben
wir hier aus meiner Sicht wirklich ein
sehr sehr guten Kompromiss zwischen
unterschiedlichen Interessen hinbekommen
das Gebäude Energiegesetz lange hat es
gedauert jetzt stehen zumindest die
Leitplanken für ein Gesetz das soll und
muss der Bundestag jetzt ausformulieren
das war seine schwierige Einigung mattes
Feldhoff konnten nun alle drei
Koalitionspartner ihr Gesicht war
na die Fronten waren schon sehr
verhärtet heute Mittag als
SPD-Fraktionschef Mütze nicht die
Notbremse gezogen hat und die drei Chefs
zu den Beratungen hinzugezogen hat ein
ziemlich singulärer Vorgang aber in der
Ampelkoalition momentan offensichtlich
notwendig das Scholz Habeck und Linder
diesen Knoten jetzt durchschlagen
konnten liegt wohl auch daran dass sie
einsehen mussten dass sie den Bogen
nicht überspannen können Robert Habeck
hat mit seinem Hinweis auf die
Regierungsfähigkeit der Ampel ja mit
nichts anderem als im koalitions
ausgewählt diese Leitplanken die die
Fraktionschefs heute vorgestellt haben
sind jetzt die Grundlage für die
Beratungen im Bundestag bis zur
Sommerpause das ist da diese Brücke gibt
über die jetzt alle gehen können erst
lange Planung und dann kommunale oder
dann heizungsentscheidung vor Ort ist
der Kompromiss der jetzt gefällt worden
ist aber muss am Ende des Tages schon
sagen zwischenzeitlich hat diese
Koalition heute in ein Abgrund geschaut
vielen Dank für diese Einordnung mattes
Feldhoff
es ist eine wegweisende
Gerichtsentscheidung die es so noch
nicht gegeben hat das Erzbistum Köln
muss 300.000 Euro Schmerzensgeld an
einen Betroffenen sexualisierter Gewalt
Zahlen der heute 64-Jährige ehemalige
Messdiener war in den 70er Jahren von
einem Priester mehr als 300 Mal
vergewaltigt worden der Täter ist
mittlerweile verstorben über das Urteil
des Landgerichts Köln berichten Michael
haselrieder und Sarah Tacke
er hat ein Urteil erstritten dass es so
noch nie gab Georg Männer sein Gegner
die mächtige katholische Kirche das
Erzbistum Köln vertreten nur durch seine
Anwälte durch das von ihm erstrittene
Urteil ist jetzt erstmals klar die
Kirche haftet als Institution für
Missbrauch durch ihre Priester ein
Meilenstein für alle Missbrauchsopfer
ich bin erstmal froh ein Stück das mir
Gerechtigkeit wiederfährt und wie man
zwei betroffen und
Opfer auch gesagt haben sie sind froh
dass ich das ausgehalten habe in dieser
Kirche im Erzbistum Köln war Georg meine
Messdiener mehr als sieben Jahre lang
missbrauchte ihn ein katholischer
Priester
also wir reden jetzt hier davon dass
seit 1973 fast täglich wenn ich in der
Eifel war sich an mir vergangen hat und
das was sie sich praktisch auf Fantasie
mäßig in allen Variationen vorstellen
können ist auch passiert
Georg Menne war damals 13 Jahre alt hier
fotografiert von seinem Peiniger was ihm
angetan wurde kann mit Geld nicht
aufgewogen werden und trotzdem macht
Georg Männe sein Missbrauch öffentlich
verklagt die katholische Kirche um Geld
und Gerechtigkeit für ihn und ein Signal
der Justiz für alle Missbrauchsopfer zu
erwirken mit seinem Mut und seiner Kraft
hat Georg Männer einen Präzedenzfall
erstritten denn durch dieses Urteil ist
vorerst klar die katholische Kirche muss
als Institution für den Missbrauch durch
ihre Priester zahlen und das auch wenn
die Taten jahrzehntelang zurückliegen
hinter dieses Urteil kann die
katholische Kirche nicht mehr zurück
noch können zwar beide Seiten das Urteil
anfechten aber die Signalwirkung die
bleibt
jetzt zu dem sensiblen Thema
Suizidbeihilfe noch vor der Sommerpause
will der Bundestag eine Regelung auf den
Weg bringen drei Entwürfe waren es
bislang jetzt sind es nur noch zwei weil
sich Abgeordnete von FDP und Grünen
zusammengetan und einen
Kompromissvorschlag vorgelegt haben er
sieht vor dass ausschließlich
volljährige Menschen Zugang zu
Medikamenten zur Selbsttötung bekommen
Voraussetzung für die Verschreibung muss
eine fachliche Beratung sein
hinzu kommt eine Bedenkzeit von
mindestens drei Wochen
die Linke ringt um ihren Umgang mit
Sahra Wagenknecht da Wagenknecht darüber
nachdenkt eine eigene Partei zu gründen
hat der Parteivorstand sie ja
aufgefordert ihre Mandate niederzulegen
Wagenknecht lehnt das bisher ab und weiß
einen Teil der Bundestagsfraktion hinter
sich die hatte heute Sitzung mehr dazu
von Andreas Kühnast
sie könnte ihre Partei erlösen sie
könnte sagen ich bleibe oder ich gehe
aber Sarah Wagenknecht schwänzt die
Fraktionssitzung und kritisiert die
Linke lieber auf einem Philosophie fest
in Köln deswegen sind eigentlich sogar
die klassischen Themen der Linken heute
wieder brennender oder oder aktueller
als als Sie vielleicht noch in den 70er
Jahren oder 80er Jahren waren aber es
sind nicht mehr die die klassischen
Themen der heutigen legen in Berlin
zerstreitet sich zur selben Zeit die
Bundestagsfraktion immer heftiger über
die berühmte abwesende ihre Gegner wie
der Parteivorstand um die Vorsitzende
Wissler wollen Wagenknecht rausschmeißen
wagenknechtsanhänger wie der Abgeordnete
Ernst wollen den Parteivorstand
rausschmeißen und Fraktionschefin
Mohammed Ali will Wagenknecht nicht
einmal dann rausschmeißen wenn Sie eine
neue Partei gründen sollte
obsessive Züge also der ein Teil findet
dass sie Gott ist und der andere Teil
findet dass sie Teufel ist
Fraktionschefs dem wagenknechtsgegner
seit Jahren einen Pakt mit dem Teufel
vorwerfen ist nach wie vor gegen den
Rauswurf zeigt aber erstmals eine Grenze
auf aus der linken heraus und mit den
Ressourcen der linken und auch nicht von
Fraktionen kann es keine Bestrebung zu
Gründung einer neuen Partei geben und
alles was da machbar ist das wird
selbstverständlich auch von uns
unterbunden Sarah Wagenknecht hat die
Linke gespalten die Partei streitet ob
sie bleibt und Wagenknecht sagt nicht ob
sie geht
zum Krieg in der Ukraine und damit zur
Gegend Offensive der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte
russlands Präsident Putin sagte heute
die Ukraine hätten viele Soldaten und
viele Waffensysteme verloren der
ukrainische Präsident selenski spricht
von schweren Kämpfen und von
zurückeroberten Dörfern seine
Heimatstadt wurde in der Nacht von
russischen Raketen getroffen mindestens
11 Menschen wurden getötet Alexandra
Vacano berichtet
es ist der Morgen danach in krimidi und
dieser Morgen zeigt was die russischen
Raketen zerstört haben
mitten in der Nacht schlugen die
Marschflugkörper in den fünfstöckigen
Wohnblock der Großstadt ein
Olena schlief gerade plötzlich diese
unerträgliche Explosion wie sie erzählt
schockiert auch ihre Nachbarin ich bin
immer noch verwirrt wie das alles
passiert ist zuerst gab es einen lauten
Knall die Autos gingen in Flammen auf
das Fenster hier wurde gesprengt es war
schlimm
keiner hat mit einer solchen Attacke
gerechnet das Zuhause der Menschen hier
gleicht einem Trümmerfeld
die Attacke auf privilegi nicht die
einzige in dieser Nacht wurde zum Ziel
von Drohnenangriffen auch Kiew sei unter
Beschuss gewesen die Raketen seien
jedoch von der Luftabwehr zerstört
worden aber die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive sie laufe da ist man sich
in Moskau sicher und zwar schon seit dem
vierten juni so der russische Präsident
vor militärbloggern doch die Verluste
der Ukraine sein zehnmal höher als auf
russische Seite mein Putin und 25 bis 30
Prozent der westlichen Technik sein
zerstört zurück in die Ukraine nach
krimidi dort haben Sie die Suche nach
Verschütteten Menschen eingestellt und
versuchen jetzt nach dieser
schrecklichen Nacht irgendwie nach vorne
zu schauen
Energie ist nicht mehr so teuer wie den
ersten Kriegsmonaten das drückt die
Inflationsrate für Deutschland wurden
heute die vorläufigen Zahlen für den Mai
bestätigt
6,1% betrug die Teuerungsrate ähnlich
die Entwicklung in den USA dort stiegen
die Preise noch im 4%. im April waren es
noch 4,9% gewesen
es ist das erste Mal das gegen ein
ehemaligen US-Präsidenten auf
Bundesebene Anklage erhoben wurde Donald
Trump soll nach Ende seiner Amtszeit
streng geheime Dokumente aus dem Weißen
Haus mitgenommen dazu falsche Aussagen
gemacht und die Ermittlungen behindert
haben heute muss Trump vor einem Gericht
in Miami erscheinen die Einzelheiten von
Benjamin Daniel
was in rund zwei Stunden hinter diesen
Mauern beginnt wird in die
Geschichtsbücher eingehen Trumps treuste
Fans sind schon seit Tagen in Miami
wir sind hier am Donald Trump zu
unterstützen und sicherzustellen dass
beiden und seine Freunde gestürzt werden
für alles dabei war er doch immer
unschuldig sie hören nicht auf aber es
wird an ihm abperlen er ist der
erfolgreichste Präsident aller Zeiten
es geht um Papiere die das FBI im August
in Trumps Privathaus in Mara Lago
gefunden hatte die rund 100 Akten zum
Teil streng geheim darunter laut
Anklageschrift unter anderem ein
Kriegsplan des Pentagons gegen den Iran
Trump soll ihn sogar Besuchern in seinem
Haus in New Jersey gezeigt haben neben
Behinderung der Justiz Falschaussage und
Verschwörung wird ihm auch ein Verstoß
gegen das us-spionagegesetz vorgeworfen
bei einer Verurteilung droht ihm eine
mehrjährige Haftstrafe
in diesem Land und sie gelten für alle
gleichermaßen wer gegen das Gesetz
verstößt bringt unser Land in Gefahr
Trump weist die Vorwürfe zurück wie rund
80% der Republikaner glaubt er die
Anklage sei politisch motiviert und
stachelt seine Anhänger an es könnte
eine heißer Tag werden in Miami
und Vater miami ist für uns Claudia
Bates Claudia wie ist die Lage vor dem
Gericht gerade
ja die Situation hier ist ein bisschen
angespannt man hört Helikopter es waren
pro Trump autokorses hier um das Gericht
herum es ist laut es wird Musik gespielt
manchmal schreien sich Menschen an das
die Trump Anhänger sind in Flaggen
gehüllt einer läuft mit einem
Schweinekopf aufgespießt hier herum aber
Trump hatte ja seine Anhänger dazu
aufgefordert in Massen hierher zu kommen
das ist nicht der Fall es ist keine
große Demonstration hier er wird hier im
Gericht in kurzer Zeit auf unschuldig
plädieren und er wird bei dem harten
Kern seiner Anhänger aus diesem
prozesskapital schlagen können aber bei
den
konservativen Wählern der Mitte bei den
Moderatoren Republikanern oder eher
nicht
der Frühling brachte zwar viel Regen
aber das reicht nicht in einigen
Regionen sind die Böden inzwischen
wieder viel zu trocken und so steigt die
Gefahr von Waldbränden vor allem
Nordosten wen Brandenburg und in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern kritisches
derzeit die Lage in Hagenow und
benachbarten
dort stehen rund 140 Hektar in Flammen
gestalten sich schwierig denn die Brände
sind auf ehemaligen Militärgelände eine
Stadt fällt unser Susanne Seidel
berichten
Flammen im Wald von Lübtheen das oberste
Ziel der Feuerwehrleute die breiten
Brandschneisen müssen nass gehalten
werden damit sich das Feuer nicht
ausbreitet seit dem Nachmittag ist auch
ein Löschhubschrauber der Bundespolizei
im Einsatz
das wichtigste ist eigentlich im Moment
dass wir die Situation genau beobachten
dass die jetzigen schneiden halten wir
haben eine kritische Situation mit den
Windböen die jetzt kommen mit den
Detonationen die dadurch entstehen im
brennenden Boden gibt es
weltkriegsmunition hohe Temperaturen
Wind und viel Totholz sorgen für die
Detonationen das Brandgebiet liegt auf
einem alten Truppenübungsplatz an den
lyptainer Ortsteil holzrade ist das
Feuer bis auf 500 Meter herangekommen
160 Einwohner mussten ihre Häuser
verlassen
ja sicher macht man sich Sorgen
es ist zwar alles versichert aber
trotzdem da steckt ja auch ein bisschen
Herzblut drin bereits 2019 gab es hier
den größten Waldbrand in der Geschichte
des Bundeslandes knapp 1000 Hektar
brannten zur besseren Brandbekämpfung
gab es seitdem vor allem moderne
Löschtechnik für 50 Millionen Euro die
alte Munition wurde aber nicht komplett
geräumt auch hier in Hagenow unweit von
Lübtheen brennt ein weiterer ehemaliger
Truppenübungsplatz immer wieder Flammen
Glutnester auf und treiben das Feuer
weiter ein Bergepanzer der Bundeswehr
ist hier seit dem Nachmittag vor Ort sie
Brandschneisen um ein ausbreitendes
Feuers zu verhindern
es war ein großer Aufreger in Freiburg
die Stadt hatte die Parkgebühren für
Anwohnerinnen und Anwohner drastisch
erhöht in der Regel auf 360 Euro im Jahr
besonders teuer wurde es für größere
Autos dagegen gab es Klagen das ganze
ging bis zum Bundesverwaltungsgericht
und das hat die neuen Regelungen heute
erstmal für unwirksam erklärt was das
bedeutet zeigt Dorothea Dörner
der Bäcker schettgen wohnt mit ihrer
Familie in der Freiburger Innenstadt
seit der Erhöhung der
anwohnerparkgebühren zahlen Sie für Ihr
Familienauto 360 statt 30 Euro im Jahr
das was es im Moment das ist nicht fair
das ist einfach nur ich würde schon fast
sagen Bucher also das ist nicht
verhältnismäßig das soll sich jetzt
wieder ändern heute kippte das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig die
Gebühren geklagt hatte der Freiburger
FDP Stadtrat Sascha vieg dargestellt
dass eben die Ermächtigungsgrundlage
seitens des Bundes anders auszulegen war
als es dann auf den weiteren Ebenen
erfolgt ist insofern war die
freiburgersatzung zunächst einmal nicht
richtig im Klartext die Stadt hätte
anstelle einer Satzung eine
Rechtsverordnung erlassen müssen die
bisherigen Regelungen sein unwirksam so
dass Gericht im dezember 2021 hatte die
Stadt Freiburg die Gebühren bis um das
15-fache erhöht ein großes Auto konnte
dann bis zu 480 € im Jahr kosten die in
der Stadt so mancher Anwohner würde aus
Kostengründen dann auf das Auto
verzichten daraufhin parkten viele ihre
Autos in den gebührenfreien
Seitenstraßen wo auch Bernd von Mahlzahn
wohnt in all diesen Bereichen in denen
sie jetzt nix kostet ja sozusagen
Parkplatz Krieg durch die Entscheidung
aus Leipzig könnte das Parkhaus dann
weniger werden das Urteil gilt als
Signal auch für andere Kommunen die sich
mit dem Thema Anwohnerparken
beschäftigen
und wir kommen zur
Fußball-Nationalmannschaft das war ja
ganz schön an nüchtern gestern Abend
Norbert das 3:3 gegen die Ukraine
allerdings auch wenn es nur ein
freundschafts- und Jubiläumsspiel war
ein Jahr vor der Heim-EM zeigte das Team
von Hansi Flick an allen Ecken und
kennen Kanten Schwächen die Abwehr des
organisiert der Angriff wenig effektiv
ja heißt für den Bundestrainer viel
Arbeit und wenig Zeit
nach dem enttäuschenden Auftritt gestern
ist heute strampeln angesagt bei der
Mannschaft von Hansi Flick der
Bundestrainer Gerät allmählich unter
Druck seinem Team fehlte gegen die
Ukraine trotz früher Führung wieder
einmal die Souveränität die
Hoffnungsträger Kai havertz Jamal muss
yalla und Florian wird brachte Flick
überraschenderweise erst zur zweiten
Halbzeit und auch das Experiment mit
einer Dreierkette in der Abwehr schlug
fehlen
wir wissen wir wissen dass wir in der
Menge an Arbeit haben Männern Arbeit vor
uns liegt und es gehen wir an und ich
bin da will ich auch überzeugt von der
Mannschaft eine Überzeugung die die Fans
endlich auch auf dem Platz sehen wollen
die nächsten Möglichkeiten zur
Wiedergutmachung gibt es gegen Polen und
Kolumbien
die steigenden Preise machen nicht nur
den Verbrauchern zu schaffen auch die
Arbeit der nationalen antidoping-agentur
leidet darunter die NADA sorgt sich
deshalb um die Finanzierung ihres
Kampfes gegen den Sportbetrug
im laufenden Jahr wird es weniger
Dopingkontrollen geben die finanzielle
Situation der NADA sei angespannt
ohne kontinuierliche Nachsteuerung in
der finanziellen Unterstützung der
Stiftung ist die hohe Qualität und
Wertschätzung der antilopingarbeit in
Deutschland gefährdet das Budget ist
nach Corona nicht erhöht worden doch die
Preise bei Dienstleistern oder auch in
den Test Laboren sind gestiegen heißt es
der Spitzensport und die Olympischen
Spiele im nächsten Jahren Paris sein
davon aber nicht betroffen hier werde
man nach wie vor strikt kontrollieren
Andrea Gotzmann wird zum 31 Julian in
den Ruhestand gehen nach 12 Jahren an
der Spitze der NADA eine Nachfolgerin
oder eine Nachfolger gibt es noch nicht
knappe Kassen dafür aber viel Arbeit für
die oder den neuen dankeschön
im Osten ein paar Wolken und etwas
kühler im Westen wieder sehr sonnig das
ist die Wetter Kurzfassung die
Langfassung kommt gleich von Katja
horneffer Anne gelinek begrüßt sie um
21.45 zum heute-journal und ich sag
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend der Regen der bei uns fehlt
fällt zur Zeit des südlich von uns so
gab es heute Unwetter in Italien an der
Cote d'Azur aber auch in Spanien von
Polen brachte hier ein kleines Höhentief
einige Wolken aber auch zu uns nach
Deutschland und nicht nur Wolken sondern
es gab auch einige gewidrige Schauer
hier im Erzgebirge im Laufe des
Nachmittags allerdings verließen diese
gewidrigen Regenschauer uns schon
südwärts in Richtung Tschechien und so
bleibt in der Nacht kaum noch eine Wolke
davon übrig ab und zu bildet sich etwas
Nebel oder Dunst sonst ist es klar und
die Temperaturen sinken auf 16 Grad am
Niederrhein und bis sechs Grad am
Alpenrand und auch morgen geht's wieder
viel Sonnenschein an der Küste aber auch
im Südwesten sonst aber doch schon
deutlich mehr Quellwolken als noch heute
und auch morgen kann es hier in Sachsen
vielleicht auch im südlichen Brandenburg
mal für einen kleinen Regenschauer oder
ein ganz kurzes Gewitter Erreichen der
Winter zu kommt aus nordöstlichen
Richtungen und so steigen die
Temperaturen in der Osthälfte auf 19 bis
24 im Westen auf 23 bis 28 Grad und an
diesem Wetter ändert sich in den
nächsten Tagen wenig im Osten gibt es
einige schauen Gewitter im Westen
dominiert Sonne bei 19 bis 30 Grad guten
Abend